welcome to this video and playing a
lender men lend the men okay from the
Netherlands let's see okay let's try the
fianchetto again here the aplex got a
wide choice okay playing this move not
without not with them with many a real
knowledge I kind of like the idea to
have some development going here okay
and should be 70 maybe just then go for
this Bishop h6 business okay just take
it and maybe just take it or not not
probably just take and get this get this
traded okay Bishop g7 bc Queen h6 total
bogus right this at least naija form
okay so i have to retreat with the night
thinking of 93 to see for maybe and this
is so am but i have queen III it's not
it's not clear that the night to e4 is
helping you much as this night is not
very well supported yeah okay you can
play that but it's not very it's not a
very welcome move strategically speaking
putting a pawn on a light square that
makes it seven bed forever let's see 92
or not yeah I guess 92 it's probably the
easiest easiest way to untangle my
pieces that's the real drawback that my
position is I have some the 91 and so on
it's not not fantastic and definitely
needs to be improved okay um how to
improve it p22 d3m this is the most
obvious way or to a forum alternatively
I have to make sure that all this is
protected and now a scope we should be
five
okay so maybe I should play this right
on night be five I just take the pawn we
should be five hooks e1 okay this was
important so it will be difficult for
him to to keep them all pawns now be 4i
NC seven okay so hmm just bishop f1 or
anything something else ambition f1 is
probably right anyway improving this and
now 9083 will pick up the bee farm pond
yeah that this just picks up before so
at the end of the poem weaknesses he has
really um cost black okay just take it
out and then then grab on before Queen
takes I guess
yeah let's consider just a 4m I guess a
for this is just just a good person
that's it basically I can get the night
off line chief resigns yeah this is some
justified it here he played those
committal moves relatively quickly d 5
is so is very very committal and I'm not
sure that ninety force is something
great in the first place but after that
I think he has has some problems Knight
f6 is probably stronger yeah because my
pieces are in some sort of entanglement
he probably should should retreat yeah
this is probably still okay it what
needs to be understood is that from
structural point of view a black is in
very bad shape he's got this pawn sorry
oops this pawn here on a light square
which weakens d5 a c5 and e5 and if i
have time to organize my pieces then
before and c7 will prove fatally week
and this is exactly what happened in the
game he need to he needs to prevent my
my reorganization here and the way it
went here it was very smooth he six hard
to do something else and now i have a
choice the compounds to go e form not
bad but this is just good as well it
keeps all the advantages and the
step-by-step blacks position becomes
indefensible here I think it's basically
gone I think it's very hard now to keep
keep the weaknesses together Roxy five
was was was a move I don't want to allow
him any direct counter places I think
really really okay this seems to be a
bit tougher according to them to the
engine
now that's true that's true this will
probably not win the pawn immediately I
can still go for fall for fun little
improvements but that's not winning
immediately if you have this is more
resilient and he was just basically a
losing using the pawn at the end the
easiest for white is to to just put the
night here and then let the upon run
also Bishop d3 King f1e 1d to the a porn
is too much and he still has very bad
pieces okay thanks for watching